the Democratic Party still has not
decided who's gonna challenge Donald
Trump a next fall's presidential
election the field of 20/20 candidates
is one of the largest in history pretty
much everybody seems to be running from
the former vice president of the United
States to some guy who is literally the
mayor of South Bend which in case you're
wondering is the fourth biggest city in
the state of Indiana it's smaller than
Evansville but it's slightly larger than
Carmel that guy's running for president
there an awful lot of people in this
race and yet the ideological range
they're allowed is strikingly narrow
everyone's required to have pretty much
exactly the same views on everything
anyone who descents even a little bit
he's immediately denounced as immoral or
racist or an agent of Russia in other
words the Democratic primary race is
very much like everything else the Left
touches it's strident it's intolerant
it's almost unbelievably dumb
congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard of Hawaii is
one of the very few willing to challenge
the status quo she's no conservative of
course she's liberal but she regularly
criticizes her party for becoming
reflexively pro war and pro corporate
monopoly she did it again last night
watch our Democratic Party unfortunately
is not the party that is of by and for
the people it's at a part it is a party
that has been and continues to be
influenced by the foreign policy
establishment in Washington represented
by Hillary Clinton and others foreign
policy by the military-industrial
complex and other greedy corporate
interests Oh spoken like an
old-fashioned liberal there is one left
but things have changed in the rest of
the party talk like this is a threat to
the private equity community now the
core of the Democratic Party so their
chief toady Camilla Harris immediately
left forth to shut it down I think that
it's unfortunate that we have someone on
this stage who is attempting to be the
Democratic nominee for president of the
United States who during the Obama
administration spent four years full
time on Fox News criticizing President
Obama
criticizing people on this stage
affiliated with the Democratic Party
you often hear Democrats claim Donald
Trump divides America okay well they
want to unite it well one way to unite
the country would be making an effort to
speak to everyone who lives in the
country but that's literally not allowed
the left believes it's wrong to talk to
people you disagree with which is why
they boycott this channel in this show
over the next hour we'll have more clips
from last night's debate but we can tell
you now the most important things were
never mentioned one word for example
nobody mentioned last night suicide
and yet suicide has risen by more than a
third since 1999 life expectancy wasn't
mentioned either it's been dropping for
the last three years illegal drugs are
only mentioned when they told us the war
on drugs is racist and marijuana needs
to be legalized the rest of it ignored
prescription drug companies were
attacked but only for charging too much
for their products not forgetting
Americans hooked on opioids the drugs
that have fueled the deadliest wave of
overdose deaths in the history of this
country 70,000 people last year not
mentioned Democrats did talk about
opportunity inequality but mostly in
racial terms everything for them is in
racial terms of course some groups are
well-off because of their skin color
they told us while others are not
they're oppressed America is a racist
country they argued again and again and
again but the truth if you live here is
that opportunity in America is vanishing
for almost everyone of all colors in
1970 for example ninety and two percent
of thirty-year-olds made more money than
their parents had at that age in 2014
only half did those are actual numbers
that tell you a lot they're not
race-based numbers they're numbers that
tell you that the American Dream is in
peril add to that far higher debt levels
and most young people in the end are
economically worse off than their
parents were at the exact same age so
opportunity is in decline and that's a
huge problem there are a lot of reasons
for one is this big business has
supported open borders with the rest of
the world in order to keep wages down we
don't even know how many illegal
immigrants live in this country we can't
even guess to within the nearest million
the best guess as of right now is about
22 million
people tens of thousands more arrive
every month Democrats don't want to talk
about this last night they never
mentioned fixing it in fact they pledged
to tear down border walls we already
have can you imagine instead of helping
young Americans to have the families
they say they want and young people say
they want to have families but can't
afford it no Democrat addressed that
instead of lives Elizabeth Warren talked
about expanding abortion as a quote
economic right and that really does sort
of sum up perfectly the 2020 Democratic
Party you're poor and sadder than your
parents were but at least the abortion
is free hope you're psyched about that